Welcome back everyone maximum effort this is
going to be my shang chi video for the deadpool
deleted scene that marvel just revealed a couple
other deleted scenes too they just dropped for all
you hoping to see deadpool in the mcu looks like
they were originally going to bring him in way
faster any tips on getting into the mcu there cork
so we'll break it all down i'll explain what was
going on with this character and what it all means
because it raises more questions than it answers
speaking of multiverse crossovers we're doing a
giveaway for the spider-man no way home blu-ray
tons of tobey mcguire andrew garfield daredevil
deleted scenes and bonus content all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
where you want to see deadpool crossover in the
marvel movies during marvel phase 4. i know
everyone's holding out hope for him showing
up in doctor strange 2 at some point because we
already have x-men in fantastic four from the
fox marvel universe coming to the mcu we should
tell him the truth but if you saw a deadpool in
the mcu in your social media feeds the past few
days it's because marvel just revealed a shang
chi deleted scene from shaolin's tournament in
macau featuring deadpool it totally blew my mind
it was not something that i was thinking about
when i saw the shang chi movie or even when i was
doing videos before it came out theorizing what
they might be doing with the film originally what
would have happened when shang chi and katy are
tricked into coming to macau by his father wenwu
thinking that his sister was in trouble and he
arrives at her underground tournament fighting
ring when they're showing him around at all the
different easter eggs and fighting scenes taking
place the lesser fights then the big main event
fight where you see wong fighting abomination
originally they were going to have deadpool
fighting proxima midnight from thanos's black
order with his katanas named after b arthur if
you didn't realize if it's been a while since
you watched the deadpool movies there's a bunch of
deadpool golden girls easter eggs because deadpool
canonically in marvel comics is a beat arthur
stan and they just kind of carried that over to
ryan reynolds deadpool movies his two katanas are
named b and arthur and they also had betty white
do a bunch of funny parody videos for the
first deadpool movie before she passed away
and they did a bunch of golden girls themed promos
for deadpool 2. but i know you're all asking now
how are they going to explain deadpool in the
mcu this early in the timeline long before the
events of doctor strange multiverse of madness in
spider-man no way home with all of spider-man and
doctor strange's spells breaking the multiverse
scarlet witch trying to mess with the multiverse
before the multiverse illuminati team shows up
in doctor strange two so given the context the
reason why ryan reynolds deadpool would have been
fighting in the ring with proxima midnight wasn't
because of dr strange's spell on spider-man no
way home because that would be the easy solution
it brought toby maguire andrew garfield venom all
the sinister six villains from their different
universes into the mcu so it's an easy way to
bring characters from other franchises to the
mcu but canonically the events of the shang
chi movie this fight here take place several
months before the events of spider-man no way home
shang chi is supposed to take place a little while
after the events of falcon and winter soldiers
so like late 2023 spider man no way home and
doctor strange's first multiverse spell didn't
take place till around october 2024 a year later
that movie ends around christmas 2024 around the
same time hawkeye takes place right now spider
man no way home is like the latest in the marvel
phase 4 timeline that we've been doctor strange
multiverse of madness now takes place a little
while after that originally it was coming out
before spider man no way home before they flipped
the marvel phase 4 movie release order but it
still would have taken place after the events of
the shang chi movie so unless there's some secret
multiverse spell or accident that doctor strange
and wong used the memory spell that they mentioned
in spider-man no way home to erase their minds
earlier like they have the joke about the party
and kamar taj that they use the memory spell to
make them forget because apparently they just
party way too hard unless they did something
during that party that brought deadpool to the
mcu and then made themselves forget about it the
only way to explain deadpool showing up in the
mcu during this fight in this part of the timeline
is to say that he's been in the mcu the whole time
which would be a super meta and very deadpool
thing to do very on brand for deadpool deadpool
is one of those characters that sort of breaks
logic and then calls himself out for it like they
do a lot of fourth ball breaks where he calls out
continuity issues let us go talk to the professor
mcavoy or stewart these timelines are so
confusing they could legit do a version
of deadpool 3 where he just starts referencing
core mcu events and characters like the infinity
gauntlet the snap iron man dying and as long
as he called out the continuity issues and how
things didn't make sense it would totally work
in the tone of that movie he even referenced
thanos when he was making fun of cable and
deadpool 2. he's too far going zip it that
but that was meant to be kind of a meta fourth
wall breaking easter egg like i said because josh
brolin played thanos and cable and for the most
part up to this point deadpool has canonically
been inside the fox x-men movie universe with the
james mcavoy and patrick stewart professor x's in
their respective teams during x-men days of future
past they explained that james mcavoy and patrick
stewart are the same professor x but most of their
movies are from different timelines that's why
they had the deadpool timelines joke at the end
of days of future past they also changed the past
creating another new timeline where everyone was
still alive in the future instead of being overrun
with the enhanced sentinels so i think one of
the main reasons why marvel deleted this deadpool
scene like what kevin feige just got rid of it
and changed it to wong fighting the abomination
is mostly because they just wanted to wait
longer to explain x-men and mutants in the
mcu and this scene just created too many questions
too many continuity issues even though they would
have been exciting questions even if it didn't
totally make sense it would have been awesome
but it would have been the only thing everyone was
talking about after the movie came out like yeah
yeah shang chi he's cool whatever but let's talk
about deadpool in the mcu mutants now officially
in the mcu deadpool would have kind of broken the
movie just a little bit you can kind of see the
marvel people behind the scenes going no no no we
want everyone getting hyped up about shang chi and
all these brand new marvel characters also there's
the continuity issue with proxima midnight because
she was dusted during avengers end game by iron
man's infinity gauntlet snap so how could a
version of her be fighting here if doctor strange
didn't break the multiverse with spider-man until
spider-man no way home later in the timeline and
even though they're also breaking the multiverse
in a bigger way during doctor strange multiverse
of madness that doesn't take place till after
spider-man no way home now one of the other things
going on here though i think they had planned to
break the multiverse and doctor strange multiverse
of madness earlier in the timeline so that would
have been a way to explain deadpool just appearing
here out of nowhere but if you look over here
here's another deleted scene they actually had
this special area inside shawling's underground
tournament where people could pay to fight each
other as the avengers characters in thanos's black
order during the events of avengers infinity war
in avengers end game like this scene depicts two
random people playing the game one of them is iron
man and he's fighting corvus glaive which wasn't
something that actually happened during infinity
war or endgame corvus glade was killed by vision
during infinity war in wakanda while iron man was
fighting thanos on titan and if they traded blows
during avengers end game during the final battle
with the younger version of thanos army from 2014
they didn't show him fighting corvus glaive during
the scenes at all so it's just a cool iron man
scene that didn't make it into the final movie
they probably deleted that just because it felt
like too much fan service like too much iron man
they're kind of trying not to do a bunch of iron
man stuff after avengers end game there will be
iron man easter eggs in marvel phase 4 movies and
references and we're getting a variant of iron man
during doctor strange 2 like the superior iron man
but it will not be robert downey jr playing the
character also i think kevin feige got rid of the
shan chi deadpool scene after they flipped the
marvel phase 4 movie order and decided to beef
up doctor strange 2 with all the extra x-men
multiverse cameo scenes and fantastic four
stuff like patrick stewart's professor x like no
no if we're gonna be doing a bunch of x-men cameo
scenes this is the place to do it in doctor
strange 2 ryan reynolds claims that he's not
in that movie if you believe him but the rumor
right now is the deadpool has a non-speaking
cameo scene like ryan reynolds won't be in the
suit and because he doesn't talk you wouldn't
know it's not him unless someone told you it'll be
just a deadpool variant from some other universe
i believe that's also how they would have handled
the shang chi deadpool scene of him fighting
in the tournament but he wouldn't have spoken or
taken his mask off so ryan reynolds would not have
filmed the scene himself it would have just been
a random stunt person in the costume so as cool as
it would have been to see deadpool this early
in the mcu during marvel phase 4 i am totally
cool with them holding off until doctor strange
2 or deadpool 3 if he doesn't wind up making the
final cut of doctor strange 2. they already have
so many multiverse cameos in that movie superior
iron man fantastic four x-men from the fox marvel
movies and they've already confirmed deadpool 3
ryan reynolds did say that he would be posting
updates and announcements about that soon my
early theory is that he's waiting to talk about it
till after doctor strange 2. like after that movie
comes out in theaters he'll start talking about
deadpool 3 more because doctor strange 2 will
explain deadpool in the mcu a little bit kevin
feige did say the deadpool 3 would be rated r
don't worry about that but they also said deadpool
would come into the mcu so i think they'll treat
deadpool 3 as its own self-contained movie with
a lot of easter eggs and references to mcu stuff
maybe a couple minor crossovers but if he does
show up in doctor strange 2 or when he shows up
in other regular mcu movies he'll have more of a
pg-13 vibe why celine dion i'm a bigger fan by the
holidays thought it'd be fun rpg 13. it's a family
movie also money also disney so it's a little bit
like the balance between once upon a deadpool that
pg-13 cut of deadpool 2 and the actual theatrical
rated r cut of deadpool 2. also if you missed my
daredevil video last week disney plus is getting
a special section for adult content rated r stuff
that parents can password lock to keep kids out
because they're getting ready to have rated r
movies and content on disney plus the reason
they're doing this is because they're bringing all
the marvel and netflix characters in their shows
to disney plus and they're all rated r tvma
whatever they call rated r in your country so
they can bring those shows to disney plus they can
also bring deadpool to disney plus eventually too
the next really big thing that's happening
later this month is the marvel moon knight
episodes are coming out i will be doing
videos for all those episodes just like
i did for loki hawkeye wand division all the
other marvel disney plus series make sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss any of those everyone click here for
that new marvel x-men teaser and click here for
my new batman movie ending and post credit scene
video thank you so much for watching maximum
effort and i'll see you guys in the next one!